[موسيقى]
ديور عند سطح الاهرامات للمرات الاولى حيث
اقامت دار الازياء الفرنسيه الشهيره عرضا
لمجموعه الخريف والشتاء لازياء الرجال هنا
عند اهرامات الجيزه وبحضور عدد من نجوم
الفن والمشاهير العالميين في الفن
والازياء
[موسيقى]
هذا التباين بينما هو قديم جدا وما هو
حديث ومعاصر يعتبر شيء رائع انا متشوق
وحدث كبير قوي مهم قوي ان مصر تبقى كبير
قوي في الفشن زي كريستيانو
قوي قوي قوي قوي
بالحادث الكبيره قوي
[موسيقى]
هذه المجموعه المدير الفني لبيت الازياء
كيم جونز واطلق عليها
دي مهمه جدا لانه راجل سيوه بتاع شركه جي
يحضر حاجه
فيها اجانب جايين من العالم كله
وحبه قوي المكان
وقرر انه نحاول نعمل
ههه
كويسه
كلها
في منطقه اثار الاهرامات حدث بينتظره
العالم
كان منهم انه حب يقول انه متعرفيش نشوف
العالم في اشهر منطقه اثريه في العالم لكن
ما ننساش النهج اللي انت هاجته وزاره
السياحه والاثار على مدار الشهور القليله
الماضيه في عمل ايفنتات عمل فاحليات فعلا
قدرنا نلفت انظار العالم اجمع
[موسيقى]
هذا العرض ياتي بعد الشهور قليله من عرض
استثناء لمجموعته في الاقصر يبدو ان هناك
تجاه جديد لبيوت الازياء العالميه وايضا
للسياحه المصريه للمسجد بين القديمه
والحديث بين المعالم التاريخيه واحدث خطوط
الموضه والازياء
[موسيقى]